[Music]
sharks one of the oldest species on the
planet but overfishing means these
magnificent creatures could be extinct
by the end of this century every year up
to 17 million sharks are killed for
their fins she despises bucket loads of
them many of their bodies are thrown
back into the sea often still alive
there must be thousands of them here
it's all for one dish shark fin soup 90
pounds for that yes I'm going to
investigate this wasteful and cruel
practice Jesus that's pretty big I want
to confront the people behind this
global trade
[Music]
who's regulating this there are more
buildings there are sharks and I'm going
to come face-to-face with one of the
most dangerous sharks on the planet
[Music]
once the reserve of the elite in China
shark fin soup is now available all over
the world
shark fin silver crab meats even here on
our own doorstep in London's Chinatown
starters a layup shark fin with shredded
chicken soup
shark fin with crab meat soup 1980 Wow
the dish may be easy to find but if you
bring up the subject of shark fins it's
a different story have you got one
minute please
could I just ask a quick question about
the shark fin soup please no no no no no
I'm gonna ask you okay Rowley as a level
of I don't know the agitated when you
start asking questions about it because
they're yeah nervous clearly because
good they're uncomfortable I think
I want to see if I get my hands on some
fins how do you live with some sharp
film what there's the lady we show you
nice Telangana just um please
as for a special hello at the moment we
our stuff
I had a friend the kalui Co came in said
you've got one behind counter no get
those my very small note are you on it
I can show you but those honey's not
ready night anyway what Carroll Creek
milk thank you so to you you sorry
so you look it away yeah of course yeah
we're only but this one live it's Jesus
exquisite not internship Wow
Jenna will Charlotte what kind of shop
no I'm the budget only one pair sorry
Kenny are you one-time shot yeah there's
about four than 80 different species
ready yeah so how much does it cost
seven nine pounds fifty four sir
so just like super easy pal god it's
expensive
yeah oh yeah there's a lot of money to
be made
I'm not surprised people are so guarded